[Music]
when we think about designer humans or
CRISPR babies as we've seen in the media
you know I think that this sparks a lot
of people you know sparks of people's
imagination to think about what one
might want to do with a technology like
this maybe not today and maybe not next
year but you know in the in the future
and it's one thing to talk about being
able to remove mutations from the human
population that caused genetic disease
and I think for many people that would
be a desirable thing to do on the other
hand it's very I think it's a very
different different discussion to think
about using a technology like this to
create enhanced human beings people that
are taller or have a certain eye color
or other kinds of physical or
intellectual traits that might be
considered desirable and you know it
sort of immediately brings out the whole
area of eugenics and sort of access to
technology who gets access who pays for
it
who decides who decides whether or not
to do such a thing should companies be
allowed to offer this as a service to
parents who want to do this and you know
if so should they be regulated in some
way it's a there's a lot of very
interesting and challenging questions I
think that go along with that and then
there's the whole question of you know
since this is a technology that is
widely available I really call it a
democratizing technology because it's
you know it's it's not very expensive to
use and and labs worldwide have been
able to easily deploy it in different
systems so then how do we think about a
global regulation is it even possible to
come to some kind of consensus globally
I'm not sure honestly the answer to that
I think that you know it's certainly
important to be having this discussion
with our colleagues and other countries
and fortunately that's happening but are
we going to be able to control what
people are doing in every jurisdiction
III think no way and so I think it's
just you know it's one of those things
that it's one of the aspects of this
technology that we have
to grapple with is the fact that it's
widely available and that people will
start using it in different ways
potentially even in the future to create
genetically altered humans
[Music]